[Musique]
bonsoir à tous et bienvenue donc dans ça
vous regarde à la une ce soir la
présidentielle américaine quel suspense
à l'heure qu'il est rien n'est joué mais
joe biden semble prendre l'avantagé face
à donald trump
nous serons sur place en direct pour
vous donner les dernières informations
et puis on se projettera aussi sur les
conséquences possibles de cette
éventuelle victoire de joe biden face à
lui donald trump est plus déterminé que
jamais il compte est d'ores et déjà
certains résultats
quelles sont ses armes jusqu'où est il
prêt à aller
faut-il craindre un embrasement du pays
autant de questions auxquelles nous
essaierons de répondre avec nos invités
et puis nous reviendrons sur cette
soirée électrique hier à l'assemblée
dont vous venez de vivre les pilotes sur
lcp coup de théâtre de l'opposition qui
a réduit la durée de l'état d'urgence
sanitaire
gros coup de sang du ministre de la
santé olivier verront la majorité a
tourné dans l'ordre ce soir mais nous
reviendrons sur cet incident et sa
signification
la politique voilà pour le sommaire
n'hésitez pas à réagir en direct sur les
réseaux sociaux avec le mot-clé cvr
[Musique]
et pour débattre de cette présidentielle
américaine pleine de suspense à je vous
le disais j'accueille sylvain cypel
bonsoir vous êtes journaliste notamment
pour la revue america vous avez été
correspondant du monde pendant plusieurs
années six ans je crois aux états unis
et vous avez dirigé également la
rédaction de courrier international
pierre-alexandre anglade bonsoir vous
sortez tout juste de l'hémicycle
j'imagine oui voilà donc vous êtes
député la république en marge de la 4ème
circonscription des français de
l'étranger ça correspond à peu près au
benelux et ça voilà que vous vous êtes
porte parole du groupe à l'assemblée
et puis nous serons en liaison vidéo en
direct des états unis avec richard
wehrli qui se trouve en pennsylvanie qui
est l'un des états clé dans la décision
future de l'issue de ce scrutin
et puisque vous êtes à à philadelphie
c'est donc le scénario que tout le monde
craignait celui d'un scrutin très serré
sans vainqueur évident mais au fil des
heures et bien ce scénario s'est affiné
joe biden fait désormais la course en
tête
donald trump n'est pas très loin
derrière donc tout va se jouer dans
quelques états clés et au dernier
décompte est bien la balance penche
désormais du côté du candidat démocrate
ont fait le point avec maïté frémont
dans cette partie on ne va pas se mentir
rien n'est joué d'avancé pour les deux
candidats qu'ils savent que les règles
sont relativement simples pour gagner un
candidat doit remporter au moins 270
grands électeurs tous éparpillés dans
les états notre fameux plateau de jeu le
voici
c'est la carte des états unis donald
trump c'est la couleur rouge
joe biden lui a choisi la couleur bleue
chacun avance ses pions et les deux sont
soutenus par la veille supporters
j'ai parlé à beaucoup de membres de ma
famille et à mes amis pour leur dire
combien cette élection était importante
certainement la plus importante de ma
vie je suis très heureuse que la floride
soit rouge d'un beau rouge
je les adore et donc trump va gagner
c'est notre beau meneur mais ce qu'il
faut savoir c'est qu'au delà d'être un
jeu de stratégie c'est un jeu de
patience
nous allons devoir être patient jusqu'à
ce que le dur travail de comptage des
votes soit terminé des heures après la
fermeture des bureaux de vote il y a
encore des états de couleur jaune sur
notre carte
les états clés et joe biden mènerait la
danse dans trois d'entre eux le
wisconsin le michigan et le nevada
si cela se confirme ce serait le jackpot
pour joe biden il n'aurait plus besoin
de la pennsylvanie l'état encore en jeu
qui compte le plus grand nombre de
grands électeurs un état clé qu'il y a
légalement deux trois voire quatre jours
pour dépouiller les bulletins
ce qui n'est franchement pas du goût
d'un des candidats
nous irons donc à la cour suprême des
etats unis
nous voulons que tous les votes cesse
nous ne voulons pas qu'ils trouvent des
bulletins de vote à 4 heures du matin et
les ajoute à la liste
[Musique]
arrêter le décompte alors que la partie
n'est pas terminée
scandaleux rétorque le camp adverse
voilà donc pour le tableau politique de
cette présidentielle américaine mais
tout cela bouge d'heure en heure on va
donc prendre les dernières informations
sur place avec richard vers les bons
soirs et chars vous êtes encore en
direct de philadelphie en pennsylvanie
c'est l'inde et des états clés on vient
de voir que tout va se jouer ce soir
dans quelques états clés ou est-ce qu'on
en est exactement comment est ce que les
médias américains présentent la
situation à l'heure actuelle alors le
curseur c'est quand même un peu déplacé
en terme d'intensité dans les dernières
heures
lorsqu'on s'est réveillée aux etats-unis
le focus était absolument sûr la
pennsylvanie parce qu'on pensait que
donald trump avait davantage au michigan
avec 16 délégués dans le whois consignes
avec dix délégués la pennsylvanie pour
rappel en compte 20 or ce qui s'est
passé c'est que précisément cette
tendance s'est inversée
joe biden a maintenant l'avantagent dans
les deux états cités plus dans le nevada
avec six délégués en clair il peut
atteindre le chiffre magique de 270 sans
obtenir la pennsylvanie dont on sait
qu'elle sera compliqué parce qu'elle
sera l'épicentre des recours juridiques
du camp républicain sur les fameux vote
par correspondance
alors justement dit non un peu où on en
est dans cet état de pennsylvanie qui ne
sera peut-être pas des tacles et
métronome on a envie de savoir ya vingt
grands électeurs c'est un enjeu
important alors de toute manière la
pennsylvanie est un état absolument
indispensable à donald run donc vous
imaginez bien que ses armées d'avocats
se prépare et son objectif il a lui même
exprimé depuis la maison blanche
s'étofferont d'arrêter le compteur de la
pennsylvanie la nuit dernière lorsqu'il
avait davantage
il l'a toujours au moment où je vous
parle à peu près 700 mille voix mais il
reste environ 1,5 million de voix par
correspondance à dépouiller
or jusqu'à maintenant sur ses voix par
correspondance joseph byden l'a emporté
donc autant dire que le handicap pour
l'instant du candidat démocrate en
pennsylvanie peut être refait il peut
encore gagner
vous comprendrez pourquoi trump voudrait
tout arrêter de manière à dire j'ai
gagné la pennsylvanie même si les sûrs
non pas encore parlé merci richard vous
restez avec nous on va revenir vous voir
dans un instant évidemment sylvain cypel
il le disait un instant richard vers
lien on s'est réveillé ce matin avec un
donald trump qui était beaucoup plus
haut que ce qu'on attendait certains
spécialistes le donnait même
potentiellement vainqueur et puis là on
voit que la situation s'est inversée est
en train de s'inverser
cela tient quoi ça tient essentiellement
au vote par correspondance
d'abord laissez-moi proposer une ouvrir
avec une note un peu humoristique mais
rappelez vous il ya quatre ans était
l'un des rares oui on est allé se
coucher on pensait clinton avait gagné
on s'est réveillé et c'était 30 et il
arrive à trump qui est arrivé à clinton
la semaine dernière
là il ya catherine dernière oui la
tendance inverse elle est évidemment due
essentiellement au vote par
correspondance
il y en a eu on le rappelle 100 millions
100 millions d'américains ça représente
j'ai calculé choix que ces 43 % du corps
électoral allemand c'est énorme énorme
c'est inédit dans l'histoire américaine
c'est inédit et donald trump partez du
principe avant même l'élection que ces
votes là serait plutôt favorable à dubaï
donne pourquoi plusieurs raisons la
première c'est que il ya moins de
retraités il ya moins de gens qui ont du
temps il faut rappeler qu'aux états unis
le jour du vote le scrutin ce n'est pas
un jour férié donc il faut trouver le
temps d'y aller il faut que général un
employeur est obligé de vous donner deux
heures pour y aller mais enfin quand
vous travaillez dans un café que le
patron dit non c'est compliqué donc ça
c'est une première raison est une
deuxième raison énorme celle prônée
gruss la crise de corne à virus a fait
qu'un nombre important a préféré se
rendre à la poste et jeté son scooter à
la poste plutôt que d'aller faire la
queue pendant peut-être une heure deux
heures dans une foule
voilà c'est assez simple donc il ya
quelque chose de la livre une opinion
mais vous absolument honteux dans cette
idée d' empêcher de les gens de voir
leur scrutin être comptabilisés surtout
en cette période ça on va en parler dans
la deuxième partie de notre émission sur
tout ce qui va être sans doute volé j'ai
réglé ça ça a beaucoup participé
et puis il ya les évolutions
technologiques pourquoi je compte si
c'est tellement plus simple de voter
demain si on peut si l'on imagine n'ont
pas passé par la poste mais voter par
internet de manière sécurisée ce qu'on
ne me traite pas par internet si on a
l'assurance que effectivement ce scrutin
est sécurisé qui a pas de possibilité de
traficotage certains affirment que des
élus républicains ont tout fait pour
repousser le dépouillement de ces votes
par correspondance et donc donner le
sentiment d'une victoire possible de
trump dans ces états clés et entendu à
l'issue de la soirée électorale
ils ont empêché d'abord ils ont obtenu
je sais pas dans quel état que cent
mille cent mille vos voix soient exclus
du décompte
parce qu'il y avait un problème sur une
machine et donc ils ont déjà obtenu sa
alors évidemment ça ira si jamais a
besoin ça ira prendre un tribunal mais
voilà effectivement si vous voulez mais
ça c'est pas la première fois que je te
dis que ça devient mais là de manière
massive les républicains ont
effectivement essayé d'empêcher les
minorités de voter par toutes sortes de
traficotage des papiers de règlement que
les gouverneurs des républicains font
adopter dans leur propre état il faut
rappeler que les états unis sont un état
fédéral c'est très important
les lois électorales sont pas les mêmes
d'un état à l'autre d'un état à l'autre
l'avenir de comté n'est pas là mais la
manière de désigner les grands électeurs
n'est pas la même et on voit d'ailleurs
s'afficher la carte à l'instant cette
carte de ses différents états vous voyez
donc en rouge les états à qui aa donald
trump en bleu ceux acquis à à joe biden
est en jaune et pas ceux dont on attend
justement celui les résultats ces fameux
swing states et états qui vont faire
basculer la sélection sont enfin votre
correspondant la vie quoi est-ce qu'on
sent monter c'est que dans chaque à peu
près tous ses états ce qu'on sent monter
c'est que le ce qui manque c'est les
votes par correspondance plus les votes
par correspondance sont dépouillés et
plus ils les s'avère qu'ils sont en
faveur des jeunes et dont il rattrape le
retard qu'elle verse à l'option lancé
quelques et à faire alexandre
quel regard portez-vous sur cette
élection américaine qu'est ce qui est en
jeu selon vous aujourd'hui ce qui est
très intéressant celles déjà je trouve
là le regard que nous mêmes et
l'importance que nous y accordons ça
démontre la prééminence cahul pour lui
les états unis dans l'histoire du monde
et de l'europe et les espoirs au fond
que l'on fonde vis-à-vis de nos alliés
américains pour les décennies à venir
parce qu'on se rend bien compte qu'on
est dans un temps de doute deux
divisions de crise extrêmement aigu
sanitaire économique social sécuritaire
et donc il ya au fond l'espoir que les
etats-unis qui ont détourné le regard de
l'europe depuis maintenant plusieurs
années déjà avant trump y avait un
tournant stratégique qui s'était opérée
déjà soit obama un peu que cette volonté
de pouvoir retisser le lien avec nos
alliés américains qui a été un petit peu
distendus et donc ça c'est un
enseignement à c'est assez frappant je
trouve deux de ses 48 heures de débat
qu'on a pu avoir en france sur les
actions américaines
la deuxième chose c'est la violence du
débat politique américain est au fond la
remise en cause de la démocratie de
l'état de droit de l'élection tels que
l' on la connaît dans ce pays et en
europe occidentale par le président
américain lui-même au fond contester le
résultat des urnes expliqué qu'il y
aurait une fraude qu' il y aurait pu
avoir des arrangements avec l'élection
on m'avait dit que ça ne crée un une
forme de précédent en quelque sorte que
d'autres hommes politiques dans d'autres
pays peut être en france s'aventurent
sur ce terrain là
je ne sais pas c'est pas forcément le
sens de ce que je veux dire mais ce que
ce que ce que je note c'est qu'on
observe aux etats-unis comme en europe
une forme de radicalisation dans le
débat politique
nous on voit bien que le débat
démocratique est de plus en plus
difficile et qu'on glisse vers une pente
démagogue populiste de plus en plus
affirmée et on l'avait vu au moment des
élections européennes notamment avec
l'irruption de ce type banane dans
l'élection dans cette élection
européenne qui avait essayé de fédérer
tous les nationalistes de marine le pen
à matteo salvini et au fond le procédé
qui est celui de donald trump
ce sont les mêmes attributs que ceux
utilisés par ciba noël et pâques et donc
oui on est dans un temps où l'idée selon
laquelle la démocratie serait au fond
impuissante à résoudre les grandes
difficultés de ce temps et que nous
aurions besoin de régimes autoritaires
et en ce sens c'est assez dangereux et
donc observe ce qui se passe aux
etats-unis avec un petit peu de pas
d'appréhension mais en tout cas on
revient que même le président des états
unis une des plus grande démocratie au
monde remet lui-même en cause l'état de
droit et le système démocratique et ça
doit nous interroger pour l'avenir la
relation franco américaine s est
clairement dégradée pendant ses deux
mandats de donald trump est ce qu'une
victoire de joe biden changerait
vraiment la donne et ce qu'on sait
quelle est sa vision du monde des
relations internationales c'est très
difficile à dire en tout cas ce qui est
certain c'est que la france doit être
capable de composer avec le président
américain
quel qu'il soit et que ce soit donald
trump ou joe biden
la france aura des relations fortes et
le plus étroites possibles avec les
états unis parce que c'est notre allié
historique parce qu'il demeure un
partenaire sur lequel nous devons nous
appuyer pour résoudre un certain nombre
de crises de par le monde
mais il est vrai que ces dernières
années on a vu que donald trump
remettait en cause de multilatéralisme
tel que nous le connaissions depuis la
fin de la seconde guerre mondiale et
même depuis la fin de la guerre froide
est donc cette remise en cause
perpétuelle du multilatéralisme
elle a poussé les européens au fond à
s'affirmer à construire ses tonneaux
autonomie stratégique on a vu l'europe
avancer ensemble
comme elle ne l'avait pas fait depuis
des décennies il appuie quelque part il
a fait d'un attrapé ray du bien alors je
pense que dans certains dans certains
pays où le prisme américain
et l'appui sur les états unis d'amérique
était extrêmement important le fait de
voir donald trump regarder ailleurs a
incité un certain nombre de dirigeants
et de responsables politiques en
allemagne en europe centrale en europe
de l'est à regarder plus vers l'europe
mais ce que je veux dire c'est que il
faudrait pas commettre l'erreur dans la
quête dans le dans le cas d'une victoire
de joe biden de se dire au fond les
etats-unis sont de retour et donc on
peut se reposer sur nos lauriers et ne
pas avancer ensemble en tant
qu'européens et je pense que les doutes
les divisions qui entoure ce scrutin
nous démontre plus que jamais l'utilité
l'importance de construire cette note
cette autonomie européenne cette
autonomie stratégique cette capacité à
décider par nous mêmes sans pour autant
nous reposer sur un allié qui devient de
plus en plus incertain sylvain cypel
est-ce que vous pensez que si on sait on
se projette dans un monde sans donald
trump
on pourra revenir en arrière ou est-ce
que vous pensez que il ya une page qui
s'est tournée aussi dans les relations
internationales avec donald trump
mais en général je dis oui à l'histoire
il ya rarement de retour en arrière
alors je suis en partie d'accord
entendre à partir des accords et en
particulier sur la tête sur la question
de la relation alors je pense que le
paradoxe oui il ya quelque chose qui
était très intéressant durant la
campagne électorale
c'est qu'il ya une et un débat entre by
day et 30 sur la chine pour l'un comme
pour l'autre
la question clef de la relation
internationale c'est la chine
paradoxalement ni dans les deux débat
qui les ont opposés ni par voie de
campagne dans la campagne électorale la
question chinoise elle n'a émergé et la
raison est assez simple c'est que ben
laden est un autre type d'homme
politique ce n'est pas un populiste est
un homme qui a une longue carrière il a
dirigé pendant très longtemps la
commission des affaires étrangères du
sénat enfin bon c'est ça qui est très
investie dans cette question là et qui
évidemment aura une attitude beaucoup
plus policé vis-à-vis de ses partenaires
et qui comptera sur l'europe dans une
alliance face à la chine ça c'est
certain
en revanche imaginer qu'il y aura une
différence abyssale entre ce que byden
dirait faire sur la question chinoise
est ce qu'il est ce que tron voulait
faire de manière beaucoup plus brutale
est différente eh bien ce serait une
erreur et on l'a bien vu
parce qu'en réalité il ya une forme de
deux d'accord d'acceptation de
l'hostilité vis-à-vis de la chine aux
états unis qui va quasiment des
suprémacistes blancs jusqu'à la gauche
démocrate ya une sorte de d'une kia une
question qui fait l'unanimité quasiment
de lecteurs américains c'est la question
de la relation avec la chine
on peut le regretter on peut soutenir
peu importe c'est un constat de scarron
pas on va pas brûler les étapes à on
rappelle rien n'est joué
ce que je veux c'est encore j'étais bébé
est né en revanche évidemment le rapport
à l'europe ce sera différent parce que
ben a besoin d'un allié de la chine
mais en revanche je pense qu'il faut pas
non plus trop se leurrer
l'europe ne sera pas la priorité de
bayel alors je le redis un rien n'est
joué
c'est très serré d'ailleurs on va
retourner voir richard verdi si si
possible richard on est quand même loin
de la vague
joe biden qui était annoncé dans tous
les sondages ça tient à quoi selon vous
plutôt mauvaise fin de campagne de la
part du candidat démocrate ou un mauvais
travail des instituts de sondage si l'on
peut dire qu'ils ont du mal à
appréhender ce vote favorable à donald
trump
la première chose je crois c'est que
biden a échoué dans sa stratégie
notamment dans un état clé qui a été la
floride n'oublions pas que la floride
elle était importante pour buydens il
espérait qu'en décrochant cet état là il
pourrait prendre de l'avant sur donald
trump
ça a raté pourquoi parce que les
retraités conservateurs plutôt centriste
n'ont pas été aussi effrayé qu'on disait
par le comique 19 et ils sont donc
restés plutôt fidèle à trump et d'autre
part la population des latinos les
hispaniques que l'on croyait être sur la
même ligne que les afro américains
c'est à dire sur une ligne un peu
favorable à l'interventionnisme étatique
que propose le parti démocrate
et bien c'est latino eux ont préféré
voter trump pour les promesses d'emplois
à court terme
donc là il ya eu quand même disons le un
échec de la stratégie de maiden ou une
incapacité de sa part à convaincre on
rappelle aussi ce vieil adage qui est
que souvent les électeurs retraités
préfèrent voter pour des gens plus
jeunes aux plus énergique que pour des
gens de leur âge genre vous savez la
difficulté qui est celle de baden à 78
ans
enfin un autre élément qui explique la
difficulté des sondages c'est qu'il y
avait des marges d'erreur les secondeurs
le disait la campagne a complètement
changé
quelque part après le deuxième débat
vous vous souvenez du premier débat
absolument catastrophique du 29
septembre
trump donne une image affligeante tout
le monde se détache de lui il était très
différent ou second débat il avait
regagné du terrain
il est reparti après avoir récupéré du
coc vide sur la route de campagne il a
tenu 14 meetings en trois jours juste
avant le scrutin
donc il ya eu quand même concédant le un
effet tron dans la dernière ligne droite
qui peut-être n'aura pas été
suffisamment longue pour lui permettre
de l'emporter et la dynamique de fin de
campagne était plutôt favorable à à
donald trump d un point intéressant a
soulevé par heure effet reverdit sur la
floride mais pas seulement sur le texas
également c'est le vote latino
alors il n'a pas la majorité des voix du
côté des latinos mais il a progressé par
rapport à il ya quatre ans alors que
pendant quatre ans quand même il n'a pas
été tendre avec cette communauté il
alors si elle a quand même érigé ce mur
à la frontière avec le mexique
non mes tableaux je crois qu'il faut
faire attention parce que dans le cas de
la floride oui là on parle peut-être
plus de population cubaine
non mais il ya beaucoup de gens qui nous
maintenons en floride
ils sont pas cubain mais il ya un fort
noyau cubain ce fort noyau cubain a été
très conservateur et très droite
républicaine quasiment depuis les années
donc de ce point de vue là ça n'est pas
vraiment une réflexion parce qu'on
pourrait dire regardez byden à gagner
les régionales
si l'on regarde si on regarde le texas
par exemple elle latino du texas ont
voté intéressions davantage pour trame
qu'il ya quatre ans si c'est possible
mais surtout ce que je pense c'est que
tous les spécialistes des études
démographiques disent que le basculement
dans le texas
si l'évolution démographique continue
d'être ce qu'elle est actuellement
c'est dans environ dix ans donc moi je
pensais pas que si basculement il ya il
interviendra dès maintenant c'était trop
tôt et si le vote hispanique left
massivement ce qu'il reste aujourd'hui
tout de même des montres at ceux qui non
plus n'est pas n'est pas acquis ça
dépendra si le parti républicain change
c'est ce que voulait george bush changez
vous que je voulais une autre politique
migratoire
celle à laquelle a adhéré gratter
république ils veulent une politique
beaucoup plus ouverte et il avait en
tête de gagner en partie l'électorat
hispanique dont kiel dont il voyait
monter l'importance donc aujourd'hui si
le parti républicain change ça la
question migratoire
il est possible que l'été nous change
aussi sinon franchement ils resteront
quand même un électorat globalement
captif des démocrates
pierre-alexandre anglade il ya un
enseignement aussi à tirer de cette
élection c'est que quelle que soit son
issue un donald trump conserve un socle
électoral très solide malgré sa gestion
de la crise du coronavirus notamment ses
230 mille morts ou aux états unis
c'est quelque chose qu'on retrouve dans
beaucoup de pays qui sont confrontés au
populisme cette difficulté à appréhender
ce socle électoral un peu caché on va
dire il ya des leçons à en tirer pour la
france pour le reste de l'europe
ok des leçons d'abord attiré pour les
etats unis c'est à dire que même si
donald trump venait à perdre dans les
heures qui viennent dans les jours qui
viennent
l'histoire selon laquelle il ne serait
qu'une parenthèse serait le fait
politiquement mais enfin électoralement
mais politiquement il ya un mouvement de
fonds massifs 95 pour soigner la mort
l'augmentent même son nombre de voix par
rapport à l'élection de 2016 donc c'est
un mouvement politique profondément
ancré dans l'amérique et qui évidemment
inspire un certain nombre de mouvements
politiques en europe et à commencer par
le rassemblement national
moi je vois depuis quelques jours des
élus du rassemblement national qui sont
aux etats unis
bras dessus bras dessous notamment avec
sting banane en expliquant que donald
trump est une inspiration marine le pen
déclarant elle même que
de malte rome la réélection de donald
trump serait une bonne chose pour la
france
oubliant que au fond quant au style
vallonné venu il y a de cela un an et
demi sur le sur le continent européen
c'était pour faire gagner cette ligue
des nationalistes qui avait pour dessein
de faire effondrer l'union européenne et
donc de créer la division quelque part
pour mieux la soumettre aux intérêts
notamment économiques et autres des
états unis en tout cas des intérêts
politiques des états unis et donc ce que
ce qui me semble évident c'est que le
tropisme et plus largement le populisme
et les mouvements démagogues en europe
prospère et se développent et l'on voit
bien que dans tous les pays d'europe
il ya une remise en cause de l'état de
droit de la démocratie telle qu'elle
était conçue avec l'idée sous jacente
que j'exposais tout à l'heure qui serait
de dire que face aux désordres du monde
la démocratie serait impuissante pour y
répondre sur le corps un virus sur le
terrorisme les débats politiques que
l'on a en ce moment en france qui est de
dire au fond suspens dans l'état de
droit pour répondre à la menace
terroriste et donc vous retrouver ces
débats de façon latente et lancinante
que se soit au parlement européen et
dans beaucoup de démocraties européennes
et donc oui il faut être évidemment
vigilant combattre ces idées là qui sont
à mon avis des idées de soumission
contrairement à ce que voudrait bien
dire marine le pen et qui sont des idées
qui viendrait affaiblir l'europe
notamment par rapport aux autres grandes
puissances si on se rend bien compte que
ce 21ème siècle est le siècle des
empires continent et que si l'europe
peut être capable de voir sa voix au
chapitre et bien il doit s'affirmer
comme puissance politique
merci pierre alexandre anglade est
revenue sur le plateau de ça vous
regarde vous restez avec nous à sylvain
cypel parce qu'on va évidemment évoqué
l'autre volet de cette élection
présidentielle américaine à savoir la
volonté de donald trump de contester
injustement certains des résultats de
cette élection
on retourne tout d'abord du côté de
philadelphie pour aller voir richard
vers les riches ap
vous nous avez décrit hier soir une
ville philadelphie qui est en train de
se barricader avec la peur d'un
embrasement dans quel état d'esprit et
la population ce soir écharpe
alors je vous confirme là nous sommes à
la mi journée que les barricades les
palissades autour des grands magasins
des banques des compagnies d'assurances
elles sont toujours là il y en a même
d'autres qui ont été installés je m'en
suis aperçu ce matin quand je suis
descendue dans la rue
ce qui est sûr qu n'ont en revanche
c'est que la tension est peut-être un
peu retombée d'un cran il ya plus de
gens dans les rues il ya une apparence
de normalité qui d'ailleurs devient très
bizarre puisque d'un côté vous avez des
gens qui marchent dans la rue et qui
vont à leur travail
alors que la plupart des rez-de-chaussée
des gratte ciels sont totalement
condamné donc la question c'est de
savoir ce qu'il va se passer dans les
heures suivantes et au fond ce qui
inquiète ici en pennsylvanie c'est
surtout lorsque les recours juridiques
vont devenir plus compliqué au fur et à
mesure que le dépouillement se poursuit
parce que c'est le cas actuellement
et d'ailleurs les autorités de
pennsylvanie le gouverneur ici et
démocrates ont fait savoir que le
dépouillement se déroule de très bonnes
manières
il prend plus de temps que prévu mais
cela avait été annoncé et qu'il n'a donc
pas de manier de matière à contestation
alors vous imaginez que si le
dépouillement se termine que les
résultats sont éventuellement favorable
à joe biden et que les avocates donald
trump tambourine à la cour suprême de
l'état et à la cour suprême fédérale
pour exiger le que les votes par
correspondance soit abandonnée alors là
on rentre dans une situation
conflictuelle qui pourrait se traduire
par des violences c'est pour ça que les
palissades à mon avis présente dans les
rues de philadelphie
elles ne sont pas près d'être démontée
merci à vous richard va rester avec nous
on va évoquer justement dans notre
décryptage à présent cette stratégie de
donald trump dans les heures qui
viennent
[Musique]
et pour cette décryptage nous
accueillons frédéric vous avez bonsoir
madame vous êtes professeur à l'institut
français de géopolitique de l'université
paris 8 et spécialiste des états unis
rien n'est joué donc on vient de le voir
mais joe biden semble prendre l'aventage
ce soir seulement face à lui et bien
nous avons donc un donald trump plus
déterminé que jamais jusqu'où est il
prêt à aller bien c'est le thème de la
chronique de stéphane blakowski bonsoir
stéphane alors c'est ça à tous mon sort
clément
si j'ai bien compris si j'ai bien
compris clément même en cas de défaite
donald trump pourrait contester verdict
des urnes
ça paraît un peu incroyable dans une
salle plus grande démocratie une très
grande démocratie en tout cas mais au
cours de la campagne
il a longtemps laissé planer le doute
d'abord il à ne cesser répète n'a cessé
de répéter que si toutefois ils devaient
perdre ça serait forcément à cause des
fraudes liées aux votes par
correspondance donc effectivement ça
risque pas de risque pas d'avoir donné
cet argent puisque a eu plus de 100
millions de votes par correspondance sur
230 millions d'eu des lecteurs et donc
c'est un argument qu'il a déjà utilisé
ce matin pour dire oui et on nous a volé
l'élection
il a fait un tweet à ce sujet oui mais
bon
twitter a estimé que c'était quand même
poussé un peu loin et donc ils ont mis
un petit message pour expliquer que
c'était quand même un contenu inexactes
et donc ils dont ils ont fait ça sur
plusieurs tweets de l'année voilà deux
vols de l'élection à cause de la fraude
comment est ce qu'il pourrait contester
les résultats de ce scrutin ben on a
déjà entendu là il a déjà écrit exigé un
recomptage des voix dans les bises
consignes et puis bon ben si la réponse
est de recomptage n'est pas à son
avantage
j'ai encore des d'écran à au dessus donc
il a déjà aussi annoncé dans le bois
d'air sur cet article
qu' il était prêt à saisir la cour
suprême pour tenir
un recomptage pour avoir un arbitrage
final donc il ya quand même s'il juge
conservateur sur neuf à la cour suprême
donc pourra dire c'est un avantage
en même temps y'a pas de raison non plus
de soupçonner des juges d'être
foncièrement malhonnête dès le départ
enfin ça pourrait être retardé la
proclamation officielle de durée une
telle élection je vous rappelle que en
en 2002 lorsque bush affronter al gore
le président a été proclamé un
simplement le 12 décembre donc ça me
laisse encore un peu de temps pour ma
part en tout cas ce qui est sûr c'est
que le domaine judiciaire est prévu
puisque on apprend qu'il a déjà des
mails qui circulent pour des collectes
de fonds manière à financer cette
contestation judiciaire pays les avocats
qu'il s'apprête déjà engagés alors
est-ce qu'il a d'autres armes pour
contester les résultats
guido 3 ar voilà c'est laisser la
perspective qui est un peu la plus
inquiétant d'un serez guidé qui mobilise
ses élections richard vient un peu d'en
parler on s'inquiète de sa qui est des
insurrections dans les rues pourquoi pas
avec des usages d'armes on a appris que
la vente des armes aux états unis
avaient largement augmenté depuis le
début de l'année notamment à cause du
cuvier donc il ya un indice qui est un
peu inquiétante
à ce propos c'est que le nom qu'on a
donné pour le groupe de soutien de trump
qui s'appelle army forme très forte rome
donc pourquoi army c'est un peu sur
certains blogs on s'inquiète voyait le
fait d'utiliser le mot a remis ce que
c'est pas une manière de de militariser
un petit peu le débat une partie de la
presse qui s'inquiètent et puis ce qui
renforce surtout cette inquiétude c'est
qu'on a demandé donc quatre hommes de de
dire avant les élections que il
accepterait pacifiquement résultats et
il a jamais accepté de le faire il a dit
on verra bien donc si vous me demandez
est-ce qu'on va assister à un début de
guerre civile
oui je vous dis ben non on espère que
non évidemment mes enfants même temps il
ya un pays c'est un pays qui a été
marquée par la guerre de sécession qui
ont embrasé tout le pays dont ce serait
vraiment dramatique d'en arriver là mais
sans imaginer le pire
son refus d'accepter la défaite pourrait
poser un autre problème se dire que même
si la digue port de by day n'est
confirmée même si le trump est débouté
son plan juridique il ne sera
officiellement fin byden ne sera
officiellement proclamé président que le
20 janvier 2021
donc ça laisse quand même trois mois à
trump pour être toujours à la maison
blanche
trop avant laquelle il peut a priori
prendre des décisions des décisions
majeures qui engageraient à venir de du
pays
et ça crevait forcément une sorte de
chaos institutionnel donc la question là
qu'on se pose c'est jusqu'où est prêt
allez donald trump pour contester le
résultat de cette élection en cas de
défaite qui n'a pas encore perdu
c'est une question que je vous pose
frédéric 12 et on sait que donald trump
est totalement imprévisible on l'a vu
pendant ces quatre années qui se fixent
vraiment pas de limites
ils contestent déjà un certain résultat
il faut craindre un chaos aux états unis
si jamais il devait être à nous annoncer
comme perdant de cette élection
alors je pense que tout est envisageable
mais beaucoup de choses ont été
envisagés depuis le départ et d'une part
on a vu qu'on était très inquiet de
manoeuvres d'intimidation et d'incidents
le jour de l'élection devant les bureaux
de vote de la part de milices armées
ça ne s'est pour l'instant pas produit
et d'autre part ça fait des mois que on
s'inquiète du risque effectivement de
troubles à l'ordre public du fait que
les américains achètent des armes même
si une partie d'entre eux achètent des
armes en se disant que si ben laden
était lui ils ne pourront plus en
acheter on a vu même les supermarchés
walmart retirer les armes et les
munitions de leurs rayons ces derniers
jours parce qu'il craignait d'être pillé
tout simplement dans un mouvement
d'émeutes
il ya tout un travail de pédagogie qui a
été fait auprès de l'électorat par les
médias par les administrateurs des
élections pour expliquer que c'était
normal que le comptage des résultats
prennent du temps et c'est maintenant on
a une société qui est très fortement
polytech polarisée on a vu une
mobilisation exceptionnelle qu'il y ait
au fait que chaque camp estime qu' il y
a un enjeu existentiel à cette élection
et que si son candidat ne gagne pas ce
sont les états unis qui vont en souffrir
et de manière durable
donc quel que soit le candidat qui gagne
il est très clair qu'une moitié de
l'électorat va être extrêmement frustrés
et en colère
le risque et les des deux côtés on se
souvient quand même des mots qu'il avait
eue sur ce groupuscule d'extrême droite
les prag boyle aurait dit tenez vous
prêts sous-entendu s'il faut agir je
vous le demande -s'il et il avait
rétropédaler après et puis de l'autre
côté on a vu aussi des images de milice
dans la communauté afro américaine qui
semblait se constituer ça remet
également
c'est une réalité tout ça ce qui est une
réalité c'est qu'on a vu aussi un
candidat démocrate qui a eu des paroles
de patience et d'apaisement
tout de suite derrière l' annonce des
résultats et un autre candidat qui est
immédiatement et partie dans la
contestation et qui depuis le début
jettent le discrédit sur le processus
électoral sur son intégrité et sur sa
sincérité et qui très clairement a
annoncé que s'il ne gagnait pas c'est
que les élections étaient truquées et à
anticiper ça alors en plus ce qui se
passe et qui était très prévisible
c'est ce qu'on appelle le blue shift
c'est à dire que le décompte des voix
initial qui sont essentiellement les
bulletins de vote dans les bureaux de
vote le jour deux hommes étaient
favorables aux républicains et puis au
fur et à mesure qu'on dépouille les
votes par correspondance le résultat
évolue de plus en plus favorablement
pour les démocrates
on a vu la bascule qui s'est fait dans
l'ouest en chine et dans le michigan et
depuis le début
donald trump part anticipé ça et donc
jettent le discrédit sur ce vote par
correspondance donc le fait que cet
effet là se produisent que le
dépouillement des votes par
correspondance conduisent à la victoire
démocrate rentrer complètement dans son
argumentaire conspirationnistes disons
que le vote est truqué même s'il n'y a
aucune preuve que le vote est truqué
donc très probablement si trump ne gagne
pas il va contester ces élections et si
les cours ne lui donne pas raison
ça peut conduire effectivement à des
tensions extrêmement forte et on va voir
qui conteste un d'ores et déjà ces
élections par plusieurs messages qu'il a
postés sur twitter on va voir l'un de
ces messages où il expliquait hier soir
j'avais une bonne avance dans nombreux
états clés puis un par un ils ont
commencé à disparaître comme par magie
avec l'apparition et le comptage des
bulletins surprise très étrange écrit-il
en majuscules et les sondeurs se sont
complètement trompés historiquement
tromper donc ça y est il a lancé la
contestation des résultats
sylvain cypel quelles sont ces arguments
juridiques pour contester ces résultats
ce que ça tient la route les arguments
qui qu'il avance oui ça peut tenir en
partie la route s'allume
il a des équipes de juristes qui
travaille maintenant depuis des mois et
des mois on dit qu'il a il
dans le tiroir 3000 contestation
possible 3000 ça fait 60 par étapes en
moyenne si vous voulez ça fait beaucoup
après bon alors si près mais il vous en
faut pas promis il vous en faut quatre
il en faut quatre symptomatique 4 avec
un fondement sérieux et c'est donc c'est
ça qui va essayer de faire ça va
énormément dépendre j'allais dire une
chose un peu étrange
ça va énormément dépendre par exemple de
ce que va faire fox c'est de la seine la
seine d'infos américaine un flow
favorable on va maintenir clairement
savoir qu'il achète 40 commandes mais
qui est une chaîne qui est pas financée
par trump qui est capable de bons moi
j'étais là au moment où obama
enfin j'étais correspondant mangue obama
battre les deux élections mais quand il
bat romney le premier qui annoncent la
victoire d'obama c'est fox news c'est
fox news est d'ailleurs le présentateur
10 qui était à l'époque très célèbre dit
l'amérique n'est plus l'amérique ça
n'est plus l'amérique de l'homme blanc
etc
nous ne sommes plus dominant et donc si
fox demain dit voilà baden a gagné là il
a gagné là il a gagné là il a gagné là
il a une majorité de grands électeurs
c'est ainsi ça sera très compliqué pour
tromper un premier article que j'ai vu
qu'il disait que fox était plutôt
apaisant et ses séries ce que vous êtes
en train de dire c'est que s'il ya que
fox news qui est capable de faire
accepter une éventuelle des lieux donald
trump a cessé parce que comédiens sont
tous les démocrates donc finalement le
seul qui soit réussi il ya beaucoup de
médias qui sont favorables à trump mais
qui sont beaucoup moins connus qui sont
des en particulier des réseaux sociaux
qui sont l'arrêt des travaux l'an
dernier a constitué les journaux sont
tous pour adresser massivement robes
hayden en revanche là il ya là il ya une
question très si fox se continue de se
taire par exemple
fox n'a pas adhéré à ce que fait trump
mais si fort que je continue de se taire
plus fox otéra et plus de chant sera
libre pour effectivement par ailleurs
je sais pas si vous savez mais dans la
presse américaine moi je n'ai pas au
moins dix papier ou l'idée de guerre
civile à part et c est écrit par des
gens tout à fait sérieux le sentiment
américains c'est que jamais la société
n'a été autant polarisé jamais et ça
c'est une situation extraordinairement
conflictuelle d'autant que l'idée du
conflit est constitutive de la politique
de tom alors je veux juste faire un
petit détour du côté de richard verdi à
philadelphie en pennsylvanie parce qu'on
a appris à l'instant richard que le
directeur de campagne de donald trump
annonce qu' il a saisi la justice pour
suspendre le dépouillement des votes
dans l'état du michigan vous pourra
pouvait rappeler un peu les enjeux
autour du michigan notamment combien
grands électeurs où est-ce qu'on en est
à l'heure qu'il est alors le michigan
c'est l'état le plus important du trio
michigan luis consignes levana puisque
le michigan à 16 délégués le oui ce
continent a dit c'est le nevada en a six
et avec ces trois états s'ils les
remporter joe biden n'aurait plus besoin
de la pennsylvanie dont on suppose que
les recours juridiques vont être longs
et vont s'éterniser donc vous voyez que
l'enjeu est très important
alors pour rebondir sur ce qui vient
d'être dit effectivement on avait dit
vous vous souvenez avant ces élections
que la seule manière pour que donald
trump accepte de reconnaître sa défaite
c'était une victoire très massif de joe
biden cette victoire massive elle n'a
pas été au rendez vous par contre on
peut reproduire ce schéma au niveau des
états concernés si dans ces états joe
biden a une avance suffisante
ce sera quand même extrêmement difficile
pour donald trump de contester la
difficulté c'est un états comme le
nevada six délégués 8000 voix d'avancé
seulement
là vous imaginez que les contentieux
juridiques peuvent être nombreux et au
delà des contentions jury des
contentieux juridiques éventuellement
une rébellion est partisan de donald
merci à vous aurez charvet rallye donc
en direct de philadelphie en
pennsylvanie
frédéric 12 et ça se précise donc il va
y avoir une bataille judiciaire
ça peut durer longtemps ah oui ça peut
durer ça peut durer un certain nombre de
semaines après il y à des dates qui sont
relativement incompressibles puisque le
14 décembre
il faudra que
collège électoral se réunissent pour
désigner le nouveau président et donc
c'est à ce moment là que effectivement
on peut avoir en amont de cette date
butoir
une décision de la cour suprême qui
qu'ils puissent trancher sur un certain
nombre de litiges mais en à des litiges
à différents niveaux d'abord pas
directement à propos de cette cour
suprême on a bien vu comment on est sûrs
qu'à partir du 14 décembre
on aura à il ya eu des discussions sur
la possibilité ou même l'opportunité de
déplacer cette date donc il ya tout un
tas de débats de constitutionnalistes de
haut vol qui sont pas forcément
d'ailleurs tous d'accord entre eux il ya
eu aussi une réflexion tout simplement
politique c'est à dire quel message on
envoie aux américains à propos de la
confiance qu'on a dans notre système si
on déplace cette date en amont de
l'élection
or là la volonté a plutôt été en amont
de l'élection de préparer l'électorat au
fait que ce soit normal qu'ils aient des
dysfonctionnements que ce soit normal
que ça prenne du temps qu'on n'aura pas
les résultats tout de suite donc le 14
c'est tranché à coup sûr à l'orangé bowl
après a priori pour l'instant en tout
cas il n'y a pas eu de déplacements de
cette date
après en fonction de l'évolution de la
situation sur que si on a une situation
de chaos total il peut y avoir des
choses qui évoluent mais on n'est pas
encore au chaos
et je rejoins tout à fait sûr principal
sur le fait que fox news est le seul
grand média que les républicains en
lequel les républicains en confiance
contrairement à tous les autres sur la
cour suprême s'était fait bien que ce
qu'il a évoqué dans sa dans sa chronique
on sait qu'elle est politisé du fait
d'une mode de nomination des juges qui a
six juges qui sont conservateurs c3 qui
sont favorables aux démocrates
c'est doit trancher est-ce qu'il faut
s'attendre à une décision en droit ou
est-ce qu'il peut y avoir une décision
politique
alors je pense que à les juges de la
cour suprême prennent leur travail
extrêmement au sérieux mais on a vu en
2000 que ils s'étaient divisés selon des
lignes extrêmement partisane que sur un
certain nombre de sujets et se délient
divisent sur les lignes partisanes mais
là on parle de l'examiner
la constitutionnalité d'une situation et
prendre une décision extrêmement
sérieuse donc de toutes façons si ce
n'est pas appuyé clairement sur du droit
les juges de la cour suprême se
discréditeraient est d'autant plus qu'
il ya eu cette nomination qui s'est
passé dans un temps très court et qui a
rogné tous les principes qui avait
établi les républicains sur le fait
qu'il ne fallait pas nommer un nouveau
juge l'année précédent l'élection d'un
nouveau président il ya des discussions
sur le fait qu'on puisse élargir la cour
suprême en cas de victoire de joe biden
donc les juges s'exposerait aussi à des
changements au sein de la cour suprême
en prenant des mesures unis soit
problématique
une dernière question il reste très peu
de temps mais d'un mot sénat c'est pas
les enfants tu as souvent en france sur
ce qu'on appelle l'état profond le dip
state est ce qu'on sait comment réagir
et des institutions du pays si jamais
donald trump refuser tout simplement
quitter le pouvoir de rester à la maison
blanche
ils m'ont tout de même 2 qui a été
donnée par le chef d'état major des
armées américaines qui a dix qui allie
que deux soldats se présenterait à la
maison blanche et il dirait ça c'est
fini il faut partir pour l'armée est
prête à faire respect de l'environnement
démocratique
après ça ne dit rien de ce qui se
passerait dans la réalité est là on va
on va très loin
c'est à dire que là on imagine un putsch
là on imagine trump et revendre les
urnes et allant jusqu'au bout c'est à
dire qu'on revient à l'idée de guerre
civile la guerre civile n'est pas à la
porte n'est pas exclue c'est une idée
qui envahissent l'électorat américain
aujourd'hui pas l'électorat mais le
penseur américain
ces petits détails restent à la maison
blanche sans être président est ce qui
peut décider ce qu'il veut il faut un
putsch quand on s'est mis des services
de renseignement à dos et +10 vialade
bon merci et merci à tous les trois
détenus sur le plateau pour pour
débattre de cette élection
présidentielle américaine dont on n'a
pas fini de parler
c'est une certitude on revient en france
à présent pour notre face à face
[Musique]
et dans ce face à face on va revenir sur
cette soirée très tendue hier soir à
l'assemblée autour de la prolongation de
l'état d'urgence sanitaire c'est le
thème de votre journée à l'assemblée
thomas des prés où exactement clément
hier soir l'ambiance était électrique
ici à l'assemblée et pour cause coup de
théâtre entre les républicains et la
république en marche vous raconte tout
ça alors ça s'est passé hier soir à
partir de 21h dans l'hémicycle les
députés examinent en deuxième lecture le
texte prorogeant l'état d'urgence
sanitaire
un texte qui fait beaucoup débat
notamment sur la durée de cet état
d'urgence sanitaire prévu par le
gouvernement
le gouvernement prévoit de l'étendre
jusqu'au 16 février inclus beaucoup trop
tard pour les républicains qui ont
proposé une nouvelle date la date du 14
décembre 2020 pour décider l'ensemble
des mesures à prendre
alors des amendements comme celui ci a
de l'opposition il y en a tous les jours
ils sont toujours rejeté sauf que voilà
hier soit il n'y avait pas suffisamment
de députés de la majorité présents dans
l'hémicycle alors je demande une
suspension de séance et vous plaît la
séance est suspendue pour cinq minutes
les débats ont donc été suspendues le
temps d'aller chercher les députés
manquant à la majorité mais au moment du
vote qui est pour
qui est contre il faut compter scène
rare dans l'hémicycle annie genevard qui
préside la séance compte un à un les
députés qui lèvent la main
et finalement il est adopté
scènes de liesse chez les républicains
et dans les oppositions à gauche mais
alors tout cela aurait pu s'arrêter là
mais non quelques minutes plus tard le
ministre de la santé olivier verront
revient dans l'hémicycle il a eu vent de
l'amendement qui vient d'être votée par
les députés de l'opposition
il est très remontée et il décide de
raconter aux députés son dernier
déplacement dans un hôpital en région
parisienne dans la première chambre il
avait un jeune homme de 28 ans de 28 ans
en coma intubé et ventilé avec pas loin
de 10 pouces seringue au pouvoir à la
fois l'alimenter dû fournir les
médicaments essentiels pour le maintenir
en pis dans la deuxième chambre
il y avait un homme en surpoids âgé de
35 ans c'est ça la réalité mesdames et
messieurs les députés
ces bourrelets valentane par thalys et
elle est là la réalité deux hôpitaux à
l'ena
c'est un la réalité landau vite au goût
est en train de débattre de ce sujet
alors que nous soyons se bat pour sauver
des vies de cette manière la note
hôpitaux on m'a expliqué que les députés
de l'opposition étaient debout pour
applaudir le fait qu'ils avaient voté la
fin de l'état d'urgence sanitaire aux
minots à la mi décembre et la fin du
confinement à la fin novembre
quoi qu'il arrive dans notre pays le
décalage était tellement total que j'ai
décidé de venir dans cet hémicycle ce
soir c'est insupportable monsieur le
ministre le chantage que vous êtes en
train de nous faire tout le monde ici a
conscience de la gravité de la situation
tout le monde ici a conscience de la
gravité de la situation mais il est
insupportable de dire qu'il n'y aurait
qu'une seule alternative comme madame
thatcher le disait à l'époque vous
détestez la démocratie lorsque cette
démocratie s'exerce dans ce parlement
vous l'a piétiné vous la voler des pieds
alors comment at-on pu en arriver là
comment les députés de la majorité ont
ils pu être ainsi mis en minorité sur
cette question les députés n'ont pas
tous la même analyse que s'est-il passé
hier soir dans l'hémicycle pour que les
députés de la majorité ne soit pas là au
moment du vote des amendements dont les
députés de la majorité était là est
présent tout au long de la soirée
il ya eu à l'ouverture de la séance une
mobilisation extrêmement forte de
députés les républicains qui ont profité
pour faire un coup politique
quand vous remplissez l'intégralité des
débats dans une séance le score c'est
que c'est quelque chose qui prépare et
je vous assure qu'on était tous bien
visible en séance on n'était pas en
surnombre
si la majorité n'a pas été capable de se
mobiliser et jusqu'à presque dix heures
du soir donc une heure après le début de
la séance c'est qu'en fait il ya
peut-être un problème d'organisation en
marche et au modem il ya plus de
majorité
les députés la république en marche
fille l'hémicycle sont très mal à l'aise
parce que tout simplement ils se rendent
compte de l'incohérence qui est celle
des choix du président de la république
voilà clément les débats qui s'étaient
interrompues hier soir ont repris cet
après midi les députés ont revoté
l'amendement voté hier soir les députés
de la majorité était cette fois-ci
présent au retour à la case départ
état d'urgence sanitaire se terminera
bien le 16 février prochain
sauf s'il doit être tranchée d'ici là
merci à vous thomas c'était très clair
on va revenir en détail sur ce coup de
chaud donc à l'assemblée et ce qu'il
peut signifier un politiquement et
j'accueille pour cela valérie gomez
bassac bonsoir madame vous êtes député
la république en marche du var et
thibaut base un bon soir vous êtes
député les républicains de meurthe et
moselle
madame gomez passage tout d'abord
comment est-ce que vous jugez vous
l'attitude qui a vu l'opposition hier
soir dans l'hémicycle
à écouter sur les commentaires qui ont
été faits je trouve ça bon c'est le jeu
politique mais je trouve ça injuste
parce que c'est vrai que jamais le soir
il y à l'intégralité des députés d'un
groupe qui sont présents donc ils ont
respecté la jauge c'est vrai parce que
vous étiez 50% des députés présents mais
vraiment les 50% face à lyon pour
qu'elle colle sanitaire actuelle c'est
le cas pour nous aussi mais jamais le
soir vous avez l'intégralité des 50%
pour vous souhaiter ainsi une politique
tout à fait c'est un coup politique
bon maintenant dont acte 1 nous n'étions
pas là nous n'étions pas là alors les
raisons je ne connais pas chacun des
siennes moi j'étais pas là pourquoi
parce que j'ai plus qu'un train par jour
et que le ch est arrivé était minuit
quoi donc moi je faisais pas partie des
gens qui devaient être là mais c'est
pour dire aussi qu'on a pour ceux qui
sont loin on a ce problème de transport
qui va être de plus en plus prégnant et
pour tout le monde d'ailleurs un pour
tous les partis j'en parlais cet après
midi avec un élève qui faisait que lui
aussi c'était vraiment compliqué parce
qu on a on va avoir ce problème pour ce
pour se déplacer donc il y avait des
raisons diverses et variées bon ben
voilà maintenant on en a pris acte
je crois que ça sert à rien non plus de
polémiques et sur ça on va revenir à sur
le fond du débat dans un instant mais
d'abord je voudrais quand même revenir
sur ce climat qui s'est dégagée de cette
soirée avec des mots quand même assez
dur assez violents qui ont été
prononcées dans l'hémicycle une vraie
colère des deux côtés qui s'est exprimé
on a entendu par exemple votre collègue
philippe gosselin évoqué dans
l'hémicycle images du crash à vous avez
vous personnellement le sentiment de
vous faire cracher au visage par le
ministre de la santé quand il a pris la
parole
vous savez c'est on est sur des sujets
extrêmement compliqué dans un moment qui
est difficile et ça on ne peut pas le
nier c'est un moment difficile d'un
point de vue sanitaire
mais c'est aussi un mois un moment
difficile d'un point de vue
socio-économique et je rajouterais même
d'un point de vue politique et ce texte
est un texte important puisqu'il proroge
l'état d'urgence sanitaire c'est à dire
les mesures d'exception est on est on
est à un moment aujourd'hui où il ya
beaucoup de questions qui remonte des
territoires et la question c'est est ce
que on donne les pouvoirs tous les
pouvoirs nécessaires
est ce que on donne pleins pouvoirs à
quel moment on a calibré ça il pour vous
là s'il s'agissait de donner les pleins
pouvoirs pour une usure et la question
la question n'est pas de savoir durée
trop longue pour ou contre lutter contre
la coved ça tout le monde est et et pour
la lutte contre la copie
la question c'est quelle est la place du
parlement à ce moment là est ce qu'on
prévoit des clauses de revoyure est ce
qu'on prévoit un moment des moments où
on se dit le confinement à tel moment
on demande au parlement de se
reprononcer et je pense que pour qui une
acceptabilité de des efforts qui sont
demandés
il faut que les représentants de la
nation puisse participer au débat c'est
notre rôle c'est notre mission c'est le
travail qui est le nôtre et la conduite
du ministre de la santé hier qu'on peut
comprendre dans une situation difficile
à mon avis c'est emporté en nous parlant
des morts comme si on en était
responsable
alors moi je porte de procès à personne
mais derrière personne ne souhaite des
morts et je crois même chiant en marche
personne ne souhaite dément même je
pense qu'il ya eu une forme de dérapage
parce qu'on ne peut pas aller sur une
forme de culpabilisation des minorités
parce qu'on a fait passer deux
amendements parce qu'on était présent
oui parce que c'est un sujet très
important puisque on traite des libertés
individuelles
valérie gomez bas ça qu'est ce que vous
répondez à ce que dit thibault bazin à
ce que dit l'ensemble de l'opposition on
valoir dans un instant avec christine
pires bonne pour le parti socialiste à
savoir que vous négligez vin vous
l'exécutif la majorité négligent le
parlement d'une certaine façon vous vous
affranchissez du contrôle de l'assemblée
en beauté cet état d'urgence jusqu'à la
mi février
sans aucun contrôle du parlement
il a déjà je fais partie du parlement
donc je ne néglige pas forcément donc je
pense que c'est pas du tout le cas du
gouvernement et surtout d'olivier
ferrand qui étaient sur les bancs il ya
encore pas si longtemps que ça sa colère
c'était une colère saine parce qu'il
faut pas oublier qu'il ait du monde
médical et qui qui l'auront qui la
ressent je pense vraiment dans dancing
sorti la parade militaire vraiment
j'insiste là dessus parce que on peut
pas reprocher à quelqu'un et que c'est
d'humanité je crois pas hélas pour moi
hier c'était c'était vraiment ça je l'
ai vu et revu cette intervention et je
la prends vraiment je la prends vraiment
de la sorte
maintenant on n'a pas le hors jeu je
pense que tout le monde a conscience
tous partis confondus de la crise
sanitaire de sa gravité du fait qu'il
faut il faut prendre des mesures
urgentes rapide et on peut pas chaque
fois repassé devant le parlement dans
des tentes dans des laps de temps court
parce qu'on perd du temps et puis a
quand même un calendrier aussi il ya
d'autres mesures à faire passer
notamment des mesures qui vont aider le
monde économique donc on peut pas se
permettre de trop ralentir non plus il
faut aussi faire confiance au
gouvernement il faut être solidaire sur
les prises de décision à adopter en
matière aux sanitaires et on ne met pas
de côté l'économique
on peut pas nous laisser penser ça et ça
cet instant là qu'il a aussi bondi parce
que c'est vrai que là les mesures
concernées l'aspect sanitaire mais au
niveau économique tout est mis sur la
table quand même pour essayer d'aider
tous les tous les commerçants quel qu'il
soit et dans tous les secteurs et tous
les secteurs sont aidés ce n'est pas
fait ailleurs et ce que nous connaissons
aujourd'hui tous les états d'europe et
voir au niveau mondial connaissent la
même crise donc ce n'est pas une
particularité donc il faut être aussi un
moment donné raisonnable et faire preuve
de beaucoup d'humilité
alors on va prendre la direction de la
salle des quatre colonnes à présent pour
aller voir christine pires bonne bonsoir
madame vous êtes député donc socialiste
du puy-de-dôme
c'est assez rare de voir la gauche a
porté ses voix à celles de la droite
or c'est ce qui s'est produit hier soir
dans l'hémicycle quand il s'est agit
donc de réduire
la durée de l'état d'urgence sanitaire
pourquoi avez-vous fait cela le problème
c'est pas d'apporter ces voix qui que ce
soit le problème c est ce qu on est
d'accord ou pas pour avoir un contrôle
régulier
la question posée c'était celle ci et
c'est pas un jeu politique je sais pas
qui a parlé de jeu politique mais ce
n'était pas en jeu politique
hier soir qu'en période de exceptionnel
je pense qu'il faut encore plus de
contrôle et plus de démocratie et c'est
pas parce qu'on est confiné qu'on doit
mettre la démocratie sous cloche
donc voila nous on a voté pour dire si
moi de prorogation c'est un peu trop
long et nous ce que nous voulons c'est
effectivement une date nous mêmes nous
avions déposé des amendements qui était
qu'ils allaient jusqu'au 1er janvier le
sénat avait voté jusqu'au 31 janvier je
crois là on a adopté un amendement qui
allait jusqu'au 14 décembre
c'est une façon de dire que le parlement
effectivement existe et encore une fois
je crois que la majorité serait bien
inspiré de s'appuyer aussi sur
l'opposition parce qu'on construit pas
lui l'union mentionne nationale en
traitant le parlement comme comme un
paillasson
voilà mais vous parlez de démocratie
sous cloche de parlements traité comme
un paillasson
on a quand même vu il ya six jours un
débat avec vote sur leur confinement
il ya eu ce vote ce soir sur la
prolongation et ce débat sur la
prolongation de l'état d'urgence
sanitaire de cette commission d' enquête
sur la gestion de la crise du coville
qui a quand même entendu edouard
philippe
l'ancien premier ministre olivier
verront agnès buzyn qui va entendre jean
castex alors oui où est cette démocratie
sous cloche et d'ailleurs je vous je
tiens à le dire j'ai voté
le conte le confinement donc en
responsabilité j'estimais qu'il fallait
nous estimions le groupe a voté dans son
ensemble le confinement comme quoi on
peut prendre nos responsabilités mais
nous retrouver dans six mois seulement
et donner les pleins pouvoirs finalement
pendant six mois au gouvernement sans
que nous puissions en reparler moi par
exemple j'aimerais bien qu'on ait un
débat sur la dernier le dernier avis du
comité scientifique du 26 octobre
quand cet avis quand ce comité
scientifique dit la deuxième vague
on l'a annoncé de le dès le mois de
juillet on a fait des préconisations dès
le mois de juillet pour anticiper cette
deuxième vague j'aimerais bien qu'on se
penche sur ce conseil scientifique que
toutes les recommandations que ce
conseil scientifique fait la commission
12 vous sens où sont elles mais la
commission denquête c'est une chose le
parlement en est une autre et c'est
notre rôle à nous quelles que soient les
députés on est tout aussi légitime les
uns que les autres pour donner notre
avis est encore une fois moi je regrette
parce que je ne vois pas l'intérêt je le
dis bien franchement sans polémiquer je
ne vois pas l'intérêt pour une majorité
de ne pas vouloir donner la parole plus
souvent puisque là pour le coup aux six
mois c'est long je ferai juste remarquer
que pendant le premier confinement on a
fait trois budgets rectificatifs trois
budgets rectificatifs cd texte voilà
très longs en général moi je suis venu
du puy de dome trois fois pour voter
pendant quelques jours pendant le
pendant un confinement beaucoup plus
strictes pour voter le budget
rectificatif
il n'y a pas eu de problème on a
quelques mots en quelques mois juste
pour conclure jean luc mélenchon parle
d'une dérive autoritaire de la part d'
emmanuel macron est ce que vous diriez
la même chose dérive autoritaire en tout
cas je sais ce que je ce que je constate
depuis depuis le début même de cette
législature et je le dis encore une fois
sans polémiquer c'est que moi j'ai eu
j'ai fait c'est mon deuxième mandat j'ai
fait un premier mandat l'opposition
n'étaient pas traités comme cette
opposition comme l'opposition est
traitée aujourd'hui c'est à dire moi
j'ai l'expérience de cinq ans à la
commission des finances où nous avec
l'opposition ou avec gilles carez ou
avec charles de courson ont travaillé et
on faisait aboutir des amendements y
compris assez souvent moins on
travaillait sur des sujets en commun là
je peux vous dire que moi depuis le
début de mon mandat j'ai vraiment
l'impression que l'opposition ne compte
enfin en gros on a raison sans vous et
voilà vous me servez à rien donc vous
êtes là parce que vous avez été élu par
le peuple
effectivement mais votre avis in copains
merci vraiment ce sentiment désagréable
qu'ils entendent crise encore est
exacerbée évidemment merci à vous créer
une pièce bonne d'avoir été en direct
avec nous valérie douez bassac qu'est ce
que vous lui répondez à christine depuis
résoudre parce que elle met le doigt
quand même aussi sur certains points
kick qui sont une réalité il ya un mode
de fonctionnement dégradé de l'assemblée
depuis le début de cette crise sanitaire
et s'inscrit dans la durée et ce cas pas
un risque à s'habituer à cela quelques
parra à ne pas revenir en arrière
non je le sais pareil mais bon c'est
chacun est dans son rôle dans ses
positions je crois que le sentiment que
quel âge je peux l'entendre le fait de
dire on n'arrive pas à se mettre
d'accord c'est peut-être aussi le fait
du nombre c'est à dire qu'on ait une
majorité quand même nombreuses et encore
nombreuses donc c'est vrai qu'on
s'adonne peut-être ce sentiment là mais
bon il ya quand même des moments où on
adopte des amendements qui ne sont pas
les nôtres et où on va dans le bon sens
et dans certaines commissions ça se
passe bien que les oppositions donc faut
pas non plus en faire une généralité
parce que c'est ça aussi qui exacerbe un
peu le cette impression-là thibault
bazin
pourquoi l'union nationale est
impossible aujourd'hui qu'est ce qui
fait que vous n'arrivez pas majorité et
opposition à vous mettre d'accord sur
cet enjeu qui est quand même lourd grave
cette crise sanitaire sans précédent
l'union nationale n'est pas impossible
elle dépend d'une volonté d'une volonté
des deux côtés
elle dépend aussi et d'une confiance
elle ne se décrète pas la confiance il
faut pouvoir la construire dans un
rapport habituel quand vous êtes obligés
de regarder la télé pour découvrir les
mesures parce qu'on vous a pas associée
en amont que ces mesures vous ne pouvez
pas en discuter en débattre vous ne
pouvez pas les amendes et parce que
c'est soi tout en bloc et rien que d'en
discuter
c'est presque une souffrance n'entendez
si le débat ne se fait pas à l'assemblée
nationale il se fait dans la société il
faut pas être sourd aujourd'hui il ya du
désespoir
il ya de la colère il ya de la peur peur
de la maladie peur du chômage et il ya
une certaine manière un appel et on le
ressent dans les territoires parce qu'on
améliore la gestion et je crois qu'on
peut le faire ensemble
on est sur les territoires on est à
l'écouté on remonte et on est là à
travers le parlement pour pouvoir
émettre ces alertes
c'est notre rôle de parlementaire et à
travers l'état d'urgence sanitaire
si on n'associe pas le parlement
derrière ça s'exprimera différemment
mais le problème c'est qu'on n'aura pas
pris cette possibilité d'améliorer
vraiment la gestion qu'elles soient
moins chaotique moins cohérente
parce qu'il ya vraiment un besoin
d'associer la représentation nationale
et pas seulement la majorité tous les
territoires les sages auraient visage
longtemps mais mes cci met le doigt
quand même sur un sujet sensible parce
que plusieurs de vos collègues au sein
du groupe en marche reproche au
gouvernement aussi de ne pas les
associer suffisamment à leurs prises de
décision sur sa vie ses dernières
mesures sans doute mais il faut aller
vite les dégâts les chiffres aussi les
chiffres de la cour vide qui augmente
qui augmente de façon exponentielle on
peut pas prendre une semaine pour
prendre une décision donc elles sont
prises du jour au lendemain après qu'ils
aient des adaptations qui puisse se
faire dans la concertation oui mais
quand vous avez des mères qui signent
des arrêtés en disant fermeture complète
des magasins là on n'est pas non plus
dans une construction
merci à tous les deux d'être venu sur ce
plateau l'émission touche touche à sa
fin on se retrouve demain évidemment
pour 1
numéro de ça vous regarde tout de suite
votre soirée documentaire très belle
soirée sur lcp
[Musique]